one of the biggest bills in the kitchen
is going to be for meat so
it's crucial you keep cost down but that
doesn't mean sacrificing flavor
especially when you use some slow
cooking magic to get the best from cheap
cuts
to get value for money it always pays to
ask an expert
and fifth generation award-winning
master butcher danny lidgate
is a man in the know one of the great
things about going to a butcher is
they're gonna have more cuts available
than most supermarkets so you're gonna
see things that people don't know about
so one example might be the beef ribs a
great product for slow cooking in the
oven
especially cooking on the bone you're
going to get more flavors from the bone
and some really nice pieces of juicy
meat these only used for mince in the
past
now people are using it for braising or
slow braising or even barbecuing it with
some really nice marinades
the ox tail are less popular now than
maybe they used to be
small little mussels make up the tail
once that's slow cooked they all fall
apart
really tender juicy meat also
oxtail is sublime in stews curries and
soups
another great cheap cut for slow cooking
is one you saw me using earlier
lambs breast it's one of the least
expensive cuts of lamb
and it's also delicious slow roasted or
stewed
here we have the shin of beef where you
can see
in the shins made up of lots of little
different muscles these are always
moving
always doing work so slow cooking will
give the best
end results it's gonna have fashion a
little bit but it should be enjoyed by
everybody it's a fantastic piece of meat
here we have some ox cheeks and when
they're trimmed you end up with a really
lean piece of meat
obviously with the cheek the cow's
always eating munching on grass
this means they need a lot of cooking
but essentially
it's a really nice healthy lean piece of
meat with fantastic flavors
ox cheeks also make an incredible
ravioli or ragu
and if you're a pork lover why not try
pork neck it's a succulent alternative
for a slow sunday roast here we have a
muscle from the shoulder it's called
feather blades
the reason it's called feather blades
because when it's cut
each piece looks like a feather the
gristle tends to be slow cooked
and the more it's cooked will turn
gelatinous giving a lovely
jelly and juicy liquid to the meat
fantastic for casseroling
pies and stews there are so many cheaper
cuts which are brilliant for home
cooking
it's important with all these forgotten
cuts to find out how to cook them
don't be scared of them they're really
economic but full of flavor
and the end result is fantastic meal
as a chef one of the biggest kicks i get
is taking an ingredient that doesn't
cost much
and turning into something that looks
and tastes like a million bucks
my next recipe turns what used to be a
decidedly unfashionable cut of meat into
the star of the dish
fit to grace any table slow roasted pork
belly with fennel
roasting works better on fattier tougher
and unfashionable cuts whether it's a
cheek or
even a neck or this amazing pork belly
it's a fantastic way to transform
cheap cuts into amazing melting
perfection
take a very sharp knife bring the pork
belly towards you so you're over it and
you've got all that pressure
and weight using the tip of the knife
i'm just sort of
nicking it and go across the pork belly
long strokes with a knife take your time
turn it 180. this time
what we're doing is just sort of cutting
those nice little sort of diamonds
but as that starts roasting on top it
starts getting nice and crispy
take your handfuls of salt and just sort
of rub it in
bend it over in all those cracks
really helps to get a nice crisp
crackling on top
roasting tray getting really nice and
hot
take a hole over fennel to intensify
flavor and to keep the meat succulent
i'm braising my pork belly with strong
vibrant spices
and vegetables crush and peel three
whole cloves of garlic
and add to the fennel olive oil in
fennel in
i like the nice strong aniseed flavor
that goes with that nice rich dense pork
fennel seeds
delicious star anise
in and just
a couple of cardamom seeds and wow
they're like little bangers like little
firecrackers incredible
lovely fresh bay leaves
get your pork skin side down
just sear the top of that fat that locks
in
all that amazing flavor then i'm gonna
flip it over and get it nice and crispy
and then i want fennel seeds embedded in
those little cracks
now some white wine the minute that
white wine hits that pan you can
smell that light fragrance from the
fennel
allow the wine to bubble away and reduce
until the alcohol has burnt off
time out the stock now the stock goes in
just
underneath the skin so it roasts
on top all that meat under there will be
submerged
because what happens in the oven the top
goes crispy as anything
and the stock reduces and brazes at the
same time
really importantly bring that back up to
the ball before it goes in the oven
otherwise it will never boil never get
up to temperature
smells incredible
slow roast the pork belly at 180 degrees
for two and a half hours
[Music]
look at that you've got that nice crispy
skin on top
you can see how much of the stock has
evaporated
put that onto the board it looks
stunning
to make a delicious rustic sauce with
the flavour packed contents of the
roasting tray
first get rid of the excess fat take a
couple of slices of bread
it's like a perfect sponge because you
just lay that
on top and drag it almost like a net
and it just absorbs all that fat
if you want the perfect fried bread
trust me
stick that in a frying pan a nice
teaspoon of mustard
whisk that in and then simply simmer for
a few minutes before pouring into a
serving jug
with your pork belly always use a nice
serrated edge knife you can hear that
that is amazing incredibly tender
that belly of pork is gonna almost melt
in your mouth you've got that sweet
meat under that crispy belly of pork
what an amazing way to cook a very cheap
cut of meat
[Music]
first up easy bolito misto a classic
italian mixed meat dish
[Music]
i'm starting with some italian fennel
sausages
[Music]
fry them until colored making sure all
sides are nicely browned
[Music]
set them aside then slice chorizo a
spicy spanish sausage with a wonderful
smoky taste
and fries so releases all its incredible
flavor
[Music]
next chop carrots
celery garlic and add to the same pan
this keeps in all the flavor
stirring the pre lentils these are
excellent for slow cooked dishes because
they retain their firm
texture and shape next add a bay leaf
and some fresh thyme sprigs then the
sausages go back in
along with chicken stock
simmer until the lentils are tender then
season to taste finely sprinkle with
chopped parsley and serve
simple to prepare a cinch to make and
packed full of delicious hearty flavors
my twist on an italian classic
magnificent easy
bolito mister
my next everyday effortless dish is slow
cooked aubergine
dice the aubergine and fry in hot olive
oil until coloured on all sides
then add a finely sliced onion and chop
garlic
cook until tender
add cooked butter beans and pomegranate
molasses
which is a sweet thick and glossy tangy
reduction of pomegranate juice
season
[Music]
next add a can of chopped tomatoes bring
to a simmer
and cook until the aubergine has a
gloriously soft and silky texture
stir through chopped mint pile onto
toasted bread and finally for a lovely
salty tang
crumble over some creamy feta cheese
minimum preparation but slow cook for
maximum flavor
aubergines like you've never tasted
before
[Music]
one more dish that uses time to
transform a humble ingredient
is perfect slow cooked beef
start by frying the beef shin in hot oil
seasoning as you go
this is a very economical cut of beef as
it slow cooks
it also makes the most delicious gravy
as the marrow thickens and flavors the
sauce
[Music]
in the same pan sausage chopped carrots
peeled whole shallots
sliced celery peeled and chopped ginger
and garlic
next add tomato puree and cook for a few
minutes
[Music]
add the shin back into the pan with a
glass of dry white wine
and the juice of an orange this deglaze
in the pan adding incredible depth of
flavor
[Music]
pour in chicken stock season and simmer
for an hour and 20 minutes
this dish is brilliant finished with
gremolata a dry italian salsa
made with chopped herbs
simply chop parsley and garlic together
and mix in the zest of an orange or
lemon
when the beef is cooked rich anxious and
beautifully tender
scatter over the lovely fresh gramolata
simple satisfying and crammed full of
wonderful taste and textures
delicious
you